we're joined now from central london by
the foreign secretary dominic raab thank
you very much for being
on the program this morning uh mr raab
and we're just talking about the
mutations of the virus that we've seen
the government decided to
close travel corridors all travel
corridors and from
next week so if you enter the uk you
need to isolate for 10 days
there are reports in the sunday times
this morning that the government is
considering putting people in quarantine
hotels to make sure they actually do
follow the rules is that under
consideration
i think we've considered all of the the
possibilities we're obviously
responding to the new variations as your
guests suggested
we don't quite know yet because we're
still examining we've got
some of the the experts across the world
in
genomic sequencing but we need to need
to check that those new variants don't
either
create extra pressure on the nhs uh
impact on
fatalities if they were to come into the
uk uh or undermine the vaccine program
so the uh the suspension of the travel
corridors is a
precautionary measure just to make sure
we don't
undermine the program of vaccination and
protection of the nhs here at home i
totally understand the arguments for
um abolishing the travel corridors and
of course the
difficulty is making sure people
actually obey the rules so i'm just
going to ask again
are you actually considering putting
people in hotels
look we will consider all the measures
in the round in terms of enforcement
we're going to be strengthening the
checks both at the border
so when people come in to make sure
they've filled out the passenger
location form that they've got that
negative test that they have to vouch
for
before they get on a flight and also
because the effect of abolishing
or suspending the travel corridors is
that people go into
quarantine isolation self-isolation for
10 days
we're making sure that the phe the
public health england
checks to make sure people are adhering
to those rules are also followed so on
compliance
as well as changing the rules we're also
making sure we beef up the capacity to
make those checks
people are also going to have to provide
as you say you know proof of a negative
test before entering the uk
why is it taking 352 days to do that
since the first case of covid19 was
found in the uk
well there's a challenge not just to
make sure that you uh have the
the tests in place but that actually you
don't have asymptomatic people taking
tests and then
discovering they've got the the virus
which is why you need the double test if
you like
uh or the test and then the isolation
actually i think we've responded
uh the reason we're taking this action
now is to respond to the new variants
but if you look at for example
germany or canada we're actually in a
pretty similar place in the way we've
responded internationally
and that is because we've tracked uh the
virus the variance to it and we followed
the scientific advice about the most
effective measures possible
although obviously other countries have
been much tougher on border controls for
a lot longer
and you were mentioning the new variants
there and given the fact that we are
seeing these new variants springing up
around the world brazil south africa is
it quite selfish to go on holiday at the
minute
well we've looked there's very clear
advice uh
which applies to all travel in the in
the uk
um is it selfish sorry well i'd look
you asked me to make a moral judgment i
think i think right now
people should be staying at home unless
it's absolutely necessary so no they
shouldn't be going
on holiday i don't think that's
appropriate it's only for um
any travel domestic or otherwise ought
to be for the the limited exceptions
that have been spelled out and
i and i do think if this is the point of
the question we've got this narrow
period where the nhs is on the cusp
we've got to protect it
we've got the light at the end of the
tunnel with the vaccine roll out we just
got to stay at home as much as possible
unless there are really strong limited
exceptional reasons for traveling
domestically or internationally
and that's the way we get through to a
better place as you said there is now
that light
at the end of the tunnel with the
vaccine um
sources have told the sunday telegraph
that all over 18s could have the jab
by the end of june is that realistic
well look we've got this
three-point road map to make sure that
uh by february 15th
we've got 15 million people the
the highest risk people 88 of those most
at risk of
dying as well as of growing advice we
want them to get their
first dose we then want to increase that
by another 17 million
by the spring that would take around 99
of those most at risk would then have
had their first dose and our target
is by september to have offered uh
all the adult population um uh first
days
if we can do it faster than that great
but that's the roadmap and
that's a roadmap um it does feel like
you might be able to do it faster
than you were perhaps anticipating the
scottish government paper published then
taken down suggested
that actually the uk could offer every
adult a dose by mid-july i understand
you probably don't want to
throw an extra target out on tv this
morning but is it fair to say things are
getting better than expected
well look at the numbers i think people
just want to hear what the raw facts are
with this we've we've
uh vaccinated um uh now
uh over uh three million if you take the
uk compared to
other countries around europe we've got
double the vaccination rate of the next
leading country which is denmark
we saw on the latest figures i think for
um
saturday over 300 000 people getting
their doses
so we have got the capacity but we're
ramping up all the time
and i think the roadmap that we've got
is the target we're aiming for
and it's a smart uh realistic but
ambitious
uh approach which will mean that we hope
by the
early spring we can get into a better
place we can lift some of the
restrictions it'll have to be done
gradually
and the country can get back to normal
right now the thing that puts that at
risk there's two things
that put that at risk one is the risks
around the new variance we just need to
take this precautionary approach
hence the suspension of travel travel
corridors and secondly just making sure
that the nhs is properly protected it's
on the cusp
it's under pressure like it's never been
under before so right now people
yes there's light at the end of the
tunnel but what people everyone watching
the show needs to focus on
is adhering to the rules so we don't uh
overwhelm the nhs which is under serious
pressure
there's been um talk as well about
supply
being the rate limiting factor so in
other words it's about getting the
vaccine actually made and
produced and given to you that are
stopping you being
even quicker so how many doses are
available now
and how many are you expecting to get in
the coming weeks
well i think the total number that we've
secured contractually
some of which have been delivered and
some of which now are on stream is 360
million or slightly higher than that so
we should have the
the the total amount of supply we've had
the
fisa the um astrazeneca the moderna
vaccines that are now being rolled out
they're they're in total i think seven
different vaccines that we that we want
to get on tap
and then there's all the distribution
but on the distribution side
we've got by the end of january we're
hoping to have over a thousand
uh local sites we've got over 200 sites
of vaccination in hospitals
and then we've also got these uh mass
vaccination sites that are being rolled
out from
uh from uh uh bristol to
blackburn there's one at epson uh close
to me
and i think that way we can provide uh
the access to the vaccine we can
actually get the needles in arms that we
need
to deliver on the roadmap that i've laid
out if um supply is
the limiting factor obviously you made
all those orders before
taking the decision to delay
the second jab to up to 12 weeks can you
guarantee that if someone gets their
first dose
of the fisa vaccine there will be a
second dose for them to be given within
the 12-week period
well look we obviously we're boxing
coxing with the right way to do it based
on the scientific advice but
what we've been told is it is the the
sensible thing the smart move the but
i'm not sorry to interrupt
i'm not asking about the justification i
i understand fully the reason that i've
decided to do it i'm just asking can you
guarantee
that if someone gets their first dose of
the vaccine there will be enough supply
they will be able to get their second
dose within that 12-week period
i think if we follow the road map and
and the supply chains that we've
set out and that i've articulated along
with the backup that we've got because
we've got the
volume of doses 360 million we've also
got seven suppliers we ought to be able
to deliver on that but of course look
right the way through this pandemic
we've had to adapt to all sorts of
different things so
um we just focused on making sure we
deliver on the road map that we've got
we got the distribution the logistics uh
in place with that we've done
the nhs backed up by uh the the armed
force done an incredible job local
authorities done an incredible job now
we just got to deliver on that
some people might be a bit concerned by
saying you know you ought to be able to
deliver on getting their second dose
within 12 weeks can you not guarantee
that on fires for example you will be
able to get the second dose
well we look we absolutely uh are aiming
for that we should be able to deliver it
um and uh and actually if you look at
our track record
which is what i think people will
ultimately judge us on we're well out
ahead of any other
country in europe we're uh a global
leader frankly
rolling out a responsible vaccine and
and i think we can be quietly confident
okay um of course the more people get
vaccinated the quicker
we get out of the situation we're in a
situation where now um according to the
sunday times
the capitals agreed a plan to lift lock
down as soon as early march and then put
aries into
lower tiers once deaths and
hospitalizations have fallen to a
certain level and once a certain number
of people
have been given their jabs is that right
sophie throughout this interview so far
you've all you've tempted me with
tantalizing media reports of
what i'm setting out is what the
government policy is of course what we
want to do is get out of
this national lockdown as soon as
possible the roadmap that i've described
means that by
early spring hopefully by
march uh we'll be in a position to to
make those decisions
i think it's right to say we won't do it
all in one big
bang where as we phase out of the
national lockdown i think we'll end up
phasing through the tiered approach we
want to make sure that we can do it in a
safe and responsible way
but but again we've got to at this point
in time
really focus on protecting the nhs
rolling out the vaccine if we do those
two things
we get into a much better place by early
spring
okay you're not going to be tempted to
be drawn on the media reports i've got
that message
um maybe you can answer this one then um
if you're going to start lifting
restrictions when enough people have
been vaccinated when does the government
consider someone to have been vaccinated
is it after their first dose or after
their second dose
well it's the level of protection that
you get i mean ultimately we
need people to have the second dose
that's the way they get the maximum
level protection
but we know that you get a very high
level of protection
um from the first dose hence the
approach that we're taking
in terms of the the easing of the
restrictions we'll as we've done
throughout this
take advice as to what the responsible
and the smart thing to do but that's why
we say
um that it won't be done in one big bang
it will be done in a gradual phased way
so that we know we don't uh undermine
the progress we've made
or put anyone else at risk so we'll
we'll publish
the approach the exit plan if you like
in due course right now we've focused on
the two
central objectives which is protect the
nhs hence the stay home message
and rolling out the vaccine which is
going as you said you rightly described
is going well um as you saying there one
of the most important things to focus on
is to get people to stay at home to get
people to
try and protect the nhs and relieve it
of the pressure that it's clearly under
at the minute
some quite concerning statistics around
today showing the number of people who
have been
in work within ten days of having a
positive cover test one in nine so
they've been ordered back to their
workplace
when they could be working from home how
worried are you about
irresponsible employers we need everyone
to follow the rules uh employers
employees the guidance is now i mean
it's changed a bit and so we recognize
that there's a
um a job to do making sure it's
communicated but it's been well
communicated
so of course any employer any
responsible employer must follow
the guidelines both as a matter of
responsibility
to its workforce but also the national
mission that we've all got
rallying together to get ourselves over
the line by early spring
so that we can actually get more people
back to work and open up the economy but
in a safe and responsible way
okay i'm keen to move on to your brief
um a few um issues i'm keen to talk to
you about this morning
with your foreign affairs hat on um
firstly the sunday times reporting
that nazanin zagari ratcliff's family
are saying that she could be freed from
jail in iran in
seven weeks time is that your
understanding
well i think that's based on the
existing sentence but
of course we are dealing with
regimes that have got her and other dual
nationals in arbitrary detention
i've been focused since uh the summer
and before that but particularly
intensively since the summer
in speaking to foreign minister zarif
and pushing as hard as we can
to get the immediate release not in
seven weeks but as soon as possible of
naznen and all of our other dual
nationals
and we'll continue to buy all the
pressure you you know as we've gone
right the way through this that the
sensitivities and the
the the challenges with this the
complexities with this and my desire not
to say anything which is
counterproductive to that effort
but we have intensified those
negotiations and are leaving no stone
unturned and i want to get
nazanin released you know absolutely as
soon as possible i do not want her
inside this arbitrary detention in
heaven prison in tehran
a day longer than is uh than is possible
and we are pushing very hard
um and and obviously uh with the um
transition in the us then the contours
and the thinking in iran
may change and there may be additional
possibilities but frankly right now
we're pushing as hard as we can
for all of our dual nationals i'm keen
as well to talk about hong kong
a really concerning situation there too
and now david perry he's a british
lawyer viewers might not know but he's
agreed to prosecute pro-democracy
activists in hong kong if he wins it
could lead to seven-year jail sentences
for
the activists now he hasn't commentated
on this his defenders would say that he
has to take the cases you know
he can't pick and choose um what do you
make of it
i don't understand how anyone in good
conscience
from the you know world leading legal
profession that we have
would take a case where they will have
to apply the national security
legislation at the behest
of the authorities in beijing which is
directly violating
undermining the freedom of the people of
hong kong and in and i understand in the
case of mr perry
in relation to the pro-democracy
activists and of course from beijing's
point of view this would be
a serious pr coup there's no doubt in my
mind that under the
bar code of ethics a case like this
could be resisted
and frankly i think people watching this
would regard it as pretty mercenary
to be taking up that kind of case strong
words there
for david perry sticking with china
over a million uyghur muslims are being
held in these political
re-education camps women have been
forced to be sterilized
what is the uk government doing about
this well as i announced last week we
brought through
forward a series of measures i think
we're along with a couple of other
countries
leading the way in doing this to make
sure in a targeted way
we don't have any british businesses
that are either
supplying tool or profiting from the
internment camps
i think it's a shocking truly shocking
set of circumstances in xinyang against
the uyghur muslims
we've led in the all the international
organizations we led in the third
committee of the um
i think it was 38 countries that
followed our lead in criticizing and
condemning
the human rights abuses in xinjiang but
also in hong kong
and we're leading by example with these
measures to prevent
uk supply chains either contributing to
or profiting from
this appalling uh situation in the
internment camps that you described
see i just want to read a recent tweet
that was sent
by the chinese embassy in the u.s it
says this
a study shows that in the process of
eradicating extremism the minds of
weaker
women in xinjiang were emancipated and
gender equality and reproductive health
were promoted
making them no longer baby making
machines they are more confident
and independent i just want to be clear
you know we're talking here about people
being forced to have abortions giving
injections to stop their periods
having surgery in some cases so they're
unable to have
children i like words of condemnation
and a few restrictions on british
business really
enough it's absolutely disgraceful it's
appalling and it's shocking in
the modern world in a leading member of
the international community
and no this isn't enough what china says
is this is all lies
cooked up uh by the west britain and
leading member amongst them what we say
is if you
dispute the allegations and the claims
and the reports there's a simple way
to clear this up allow the un human
rights commissioner
to visit and access and see these sites
and we are pushing for an authoritative
third party
like the human rights the the high
commissioner for human rights
at the un to conduct uh that visit and
that is the straightforward way if china
denies these allegations and they can be
verified
and so we are leading from the front not
just in the supply chain measures the
condemnation the words you described
but also pushing to get the action at
the international level which is where
it's most effective
to get proper transparency
and then to get the accountability that
i agree we need
talking about the international effort
joe biden's campaign has
described the oppression as genocide do
you think it's genocide and will you
commit
now to putting it on the agenda when you
host the g7
summit in cornwall in june i think it's
uh it is for a court to decide whether
the very
uh complex definition of genocide is met
but what is clear
frankly whatever the legal label that
you put on it is that there are
convincing uh and persuasive uh
third-party authoritative reports of
serious
violations of human rights uh on an
appalling industrial scale
and yes absolutely uh you mentioned the
the
president-elect biden who will next
wednesday become president one of the
things we're excited to do
working with the new administration is
making sure that human rights
protecting democracy is on the agenda
and yes as we
uh presided the g7 and this is exciting
year for international leadership for
the uk
that will be the case and i've already
talked about this with nancy pelosi
speaker
speaker pelosi of the house of
representatives uh recently including
speaking to her
over the christmas period now we are out
of time but i am going to squeeze one
more quick question in if you'll forgive
me
um it's donald trump's final weekend in
the white house i've got an interview
that we're going to play in just a
moment with james comey the fbi director
he fired
he said he's looking forward to trump
standing on the front lawn shouting at
cars in his bathrobe
and none of us will hear it i mean you
spent quite a long time over the last
few years responding to donald trump's
tweets are you quite looking forward to
that
look it's the job of the british
government and certainly as foreign
secretaries make the
best of for our relations with whoever's
in the white house
um i think we've seen some pretty
shocking scenes in terms of capitol hill
recently the prime minister's been very
clear on all of that we're very focused
on wednesday when there's a
new president and a new team making sure
that in our g7 presence a year when
we're hosting cop 26
here uh the climate change talks that we
can work with our
the new u.s administration on human
rights on covid on climate change on all
of those areas
we need to bring countries together to
tackle these global problems